Democratic presidential hopeful Bernie
Sanders of course in the news yeah he
made made headlines yesterday when he
held a rally outside a Walmart
stockholders meeting yeah Bernie has
been very critical of the company
recently he aired some of his specific
complaints to a group of Walmart
employees and I think he made some
pretty compelling points here's the
footage of Bernie talking them outside
the Walmart take a look you have a
company here worth about a hundred and
seventy five billion dollars and yet
their store only stocks
three varieties of dill pickles a
pickled herring also they stopped
carrying Charleston chew remember tossed
in June yes do you know how much Walmart
charges for a pair of corduroy trousers
thirty-eight dollars I remember when I
could go down to the Bloomingdale's on
third is 59th Avenue and get a pair of
heads for 75 cents as for the website
when I see the word laxatives underneath
the picture of a laxative it's unclear
as to whether I should click on the
words all the pictures
[Applause]